tant que bonne guyanaise je peux pas ne
pas lui poser cette question pourquoi
ces mesures de sécurité ne sont elles
pas applicable sur le territoire
guyanais ont mis la surveillance du sang
spatiale afin de faire respecter notre
souveraineté malgré les relations de
coopération avec les pays voisins tels
que le surinam le brésil et le guyana
dans le domaine de la pêche et vous
savez monsieur le directeur les pêcheurs
guyanais souffre de cette carence de
protection et de respect de nos eaux
territoriales
comment devons-nous procédé où j'ai bien
compris que les outre-mer les autres
maires étaient délaissées et qu'en fait
nous n'étions que des bijoux de famille
sans importance et c'est bien dommage as
t on le sait ce sont les outre-mer qui
font justement la force la puissance de
deux de leurs émissions avec voilà les
neuf patrouilleurs outre-mer et antilles
guyane qui qui seront présents est-ce
que ça suffira pour répondre aux
demandes et là je pense que
on rentre tout à fait dans les questions
de
sur sur la guyane qui m'ont été posées
par par la sénatrice
de savoir si on ne va pas avoir besoin
de densifier ses moyens notamment
de patrouille maritime
aussi bien dans les airs que sur les
flots allah allah à la mesure des
menaces qui sont les nôtres et des
menaces sur la souveraineté économique
c'est à dire que la pêche illégale
elle va pas elle se maintenir au niveau
où elle était il ya 40 ans on va rester
quand même à mon sens sur un dispositif
qui est
voilà qui effectivement taillée au plus
juste donc passée
augmenté d'un patrouilleur
supplémentaires
chacune des forces
à l'horizon 2030 à mon sens c'est
quelque chose à prendre en compte avec
sérieux si on veut pas avoir
l'effet et l'accroissement du pillage
des ressources et la mise à mal de de
nos pêcheurs et de et de nos moyens sur
sur la guyane donc l'art densification
des moyens de patrouille outre mer le
développement de moyens aériens de
surveillance maritime à mon sens en
guyane
devrait être également considéré au delà
effectivement du csg qui ne qui ne peut
pas accaparer toutes les ressources
militaires c'est pas c'est pas le cas
mais en tout cas la lagune ici ça doit
être bien pris en compte que la guyane
ne se limite pas au csg de kourou
évidemment les forces armées le ca
l'utilisation des
des signaux à hiesse qui souvent
indiquée comme permettant de faciliter
le travail des patrouilleurs outre mer
doit pas être non plus considéré comme
au delà de ce que ça peut apporter dans
la mesure où les embarcations de fortune
type brésilienne ou surinamienne souvent
qualifié de tapouilles
ne fonctionne pas avec les réseaux y'est
c'est donc sont pas forcément faciles à
signaler par par des systèmes
déjà pré définis d'où l'importance si on
veut d'utiliser du spatial de
deux d'autres formes via l'imagerie par
exemple
qui est une capacité d analyse fine
puisqu'on parle de l'embarcation quand
même très légère pour pour renforcer
l'efficacité
un autre aspect pour pour la le
renforcement de la résilience c'est
aussi le renforcement de la filière
pêche elle même et là je parle de la
guyane mais pas uniquement